contrairement à la division qui fait
rage au niveau national l'élection à la
présidence de l'UMP dans les Yvelines
n'a pas fait l'objet de discussion elle
a été remportée par François Fillon l'ex
Premier ministre remporte plus de 59%
des suffrages pour 40 % de vote pour
Jean-François Copé sur 10793 inscrits
6361 votants se sont déplacés jusqu'aux
urnes une bonne participation qui veut
dire que c'est une campagne qui a bien
intéressé nous militants et
qu'aujourd'hui à l'UMP on a une démarche
citoyenne et les militants ont été votés
François Fillon remporte la victoire sur
la plupart des circonscriptions sur la
première circonscription François Fillon
obtient 62% des votes contre 37%
seulement pour Jean-François Copé 71%
sur la deuxième contre 28% pour
Jean-François Copé sans la troisième 58%
pour François Fillon 41% pour
Jean-François Copé pourtant soutenu par
Henri Guaino député de cette
circonscription
sur la 10e fief de Jean-Frédéric Poisson
soutient également de Jean-François Copé
l'ex Premier ministre enregistre 58% des
voix contre 41% pour le maire de Meaux
sur la 11e François Fillon obtient 56 %
contre 43 % pour Jean-François Copé
enfin sur la 12e le score est de 55 %
pour François Fillon contre 44 % pour
Jean-François Copé les deux hommes
étaient venus ces derniers jours dans le
département pour s'exprimer auprès des
militants à commencer par François
Fillon à Poissy mardi 13 novembre
entouré de ses soutiens
il n'est plus là pour satisfaire son ego
plus du tout il me l'a voulu même
et donc on a besoin de ça pour conduire
l'UMP et la droite et pour rassembler au
plus large regagner dans les urnes dès
2014 avec François Fillon c'est possible
parce que c'est le seul qui peut à la
fois être suffisamment
ramené les électeurs qui sont partis au
front national et en même temps
suffisamment républicain ouvert serein
pour nous ramener les électeurs
centrices qui sont partis voter Hollande
samedi dernier Jean-François Copé était
quant à lui à Saint-Germain-en-Laye le
maire de Meaux avait souhaité rencontrer
les Yvelinois pour son dernier meeting
le département où il a grandi un
département qui ne lui aura pas pour tes
chances mais samedi soir Jean-François
Copé et ses soutiens avaient prévenu pas
de division à l'issue des votes
il nous faudra naturellement nous
rassembler je les dis si je suis élu
dans l'heure qui suit j'appellerai
François Fillon et tous ceux qui ne
m'ont pas soutenu pour une famille
politique rassemblée pour l'avenir je
suis sûr que les gens soient Clopé et
François Fillon feront tout pour que tu
marches mais vraiment sincèrement
l'homme de la situation aujourd'hui
contenu de la France que nous sommes
dans l'opposition l'homme de la
situation c'est Jean-François
dimanche le bureau de vote d'Élancourt a
vu les militants se déplacer en nombre
pour exprimer leur choix parfois avec
une file d'attente de plus d'une heure
un choix pas si tranché que ça pour tous
les deux sont
ils sont peut-être un petit peu
différents mais je pense que l'un comme
l'autre ont des grandes valeurs pour
défendre la force le vote au niveau
national est pour leur toujours
incertain mais les militants yvelinois
eux ont bel et bien tranchées